there we go we are live it's going on
anybody's well not much
destiny is trying to redeem itself one
piece at a time and we've got a lot to
discuss and a lot to look forward to so
yeah a lot going on these uh this week
specifically so uh as you already know
we created this a slow flashpoint thing
to kind of you know we still love it we
still let his game and all it's just
really cool to see them at least trying
to attempt to address the concerns of
the community and also to let people
know if it's actually safe to come back
yet much longer than others but at least
they're communicating and it's awesome
to see so exactly exactly so let's get
it well we had one patch come out on
Tuesday so this was the January 30th
patch they had discussed previously we
talked about so what can I hit the high
points couple things that were new so
armor master works did launch you guys
know about that they stack I mean I like
that they're there they're definitely
something to grind forward so I mean we
talked about our ups and downs with them
you get any thoughts on those they're
pretty much the same it'll change yeah I
actually haven't gotten one yet so I'm a
little upset have really want one like I
was really looking at and the orange
Jesus has not been good to me right now
so yeah but I'm definitely looking
forward to it and then um you know
obviously getting a complete set and uh
you know rocking out see what that
damage reduction does nice yeah I was
like I'm looking forward to it and as we
said it's like and they even mentioned
I've heard seeing Christopher Barrett
say it's like hey we know this you know
damage reduction doesn't help all super
so they're still looking at ways to make
it even better which nice it says it
right there so I mean they're gonna work
on some of that stuff later on but at
this point it does help the roaming
supers which you know they could have
used a little boost and more from the
future so a little piece at a time we'll
take what we can get get the raid
minutes notes yeah so Benedict 99 he's
gonna be selling his rotating stock of
weapons and armor and I like the fact
that they actually have to complete the
raid each week yes yes
I was like that doesn't make it a little
hard you can't just like I mean yeah you
could save up tokens but the only way
you're saving up tokens is doing the
rate anyway so you have to do it that
week so it gives people least incentive
to do a raid on a certain week which you
know I'm not still totally 100% sold on
buying things but they did say you can't
get a master work from the vendor so if
you want the good stuff you just got to
play the raid more which you know again
more incentive for the raid is a good
thing so I like exactly I'm all about it
I was number last week I was a little
concerned but I have to sync the
implementation and seeing that you have
to run the way rate I do like it yeah so
it's night and that's kind of the thing
it helps with I mean when we were
forever 29 on destiny 1 and you're
sitting there like I just need the helm
I've run this thing like on all three
characters you did that enough and
finally you're like alright I just need
the helm on my Titan then I can buy it
this week then you'd be able to so I
mean at least it'd give you a reason to
be like hey if I'm not playing this week
but maybe an too excited you know log in
and see the helm is available to buy I
can run it if I don't get it but at
least then I could go buy it so gives
you a reason to still jump back in
occasionally if you're working on full
set so absolutely
let's go let's get it solutely raid
encounters drop at least one item so I
think it's gonna be throwing a lot of
gear at you anyway which is good drop
rate for master works so pretty much
doubles looked at maces little quick
video that he had me I think the loot
just gonna throw up on him he was doing
it on prestige the prestige was like
quadruple drops it was just bananas nice
let's see then we've got the I've seen a
couple people get to ghost but it is its
elusive right now so definitely will be
hard to get so a little bit of grinding
for that one and then the mods I've
heard pretty positive things about so I
mean even people like that us and hey
the mods make the raid a different
experience and I like the way I mean
even he phrase that would have been
makes sense it's like if you're gonna
get a bonus for melee killing something
you might you know find a smaller guy
mail it and then have you know a more
powerful rocket to go blast a mini major
with or something like that so it
changes the way you play absolutely and
then you still have a chance and exotics
and all that stuff I don't know if this
was intentional I know for the sandbox
Prometheus Lynn's got boosted oh thank
god
okay
that's what I'm talking a lot it's
actually a lot better and that was
actually the first exotic I got for the
weeks actually nice wasn't turn in it's
like Prometheus lanes it's like alright
you can go try this I just like the way
it generates ammo instead of pulling
from yeah that's really consistent DPS
on like you know mobs and just keep
going love it yeah that little circle if
you hit enough of him as massive so it's
kind of cool lucky pants just fixed an
issue where there was some infinite ammo
opinion aspect fixed another issue
little stuff but I think some of this is
honestly just if they know something
they can like fix a little thing or
there's something they know and they can
throw it in the patch they're gonna do
it I think that's cool
general activities I think most of it's
pretty reasonable I like this one right
here loss sectors reward throttle it's a
step in the right direction it's like
literally what we said last week just
you know taking from ten to five minutes
they're still working on a better fix
but at least this one five minutes you
probably won't run into it nearly as
frequently
that's first yeah thank you about five
minutes to do one issue so that one's
pretty cool anything else on the you
know activities and UI stuff that you
know of um pretty much it I mean you
know I'm just happy that my phidian's
got their little fix going on as far as
the UM activities and stuff definitely
like the you know the mercury challenges
thing you know um heroic adventures bit
and you know lost sector is always a
little touchy but um definitely
definitely like I said it's more like
quality of life kind of things and I
felt that they needed to take care of
yeah and like I mean they're just
getting what they can in each patch I
mean not everybody knows how development
cycle works for stuff but you're gonna
have like priority things get in what
you can whatever you can to my
development cycle I mean if they're
running like agile and they're doing
this stuff like once a month you like
through a development cycle get rid and
plan it makes you have a certification
launch it out so I mean they're doing
what they can with the time they have
and we'll cover more that on the roadmap
because they want to do UI basics
nothing too crazy just fixing little 401
data kora one or that handy I was
driving me nuts every time I come to
town she's got on top of her head that
was driving me nothing
and you know very happy about that one I
like his players in social spaces
receive a notification when their
postmaster is full which is nice sounds
like if you know as we were saying like
if you run through and fact that that's
gonna get fixed that's really cool
this was the other one so there's been
an issue they know it's a like a bug
with it with the API and stuff like that
so there's bugs they're working on it
but the amount of experience for an
illuminated Engram dropping 40k that's
cool let me say more frequently they got
the wristlet before I think they're just
like hey if you guys want you know
cosmetic stuff you guys are gonna be
able to get it easier easier so yep just
low on the price of things for these
boons which was nice pretty basic stuff
so I mean most of its in there if you
guys want to read the patch notes but if
you guys haven't seen the number-two
comic is out there it's a good one and
honestly kind of shows
Sheils a different side of a specific
character on the cover right in this
region yeah yeah he's a he's not too
keen on sharing that whole power design
if something's not in his way it's like
I have a nickname for him what is that I
call him the charlatan when you go to
brother vids and he'd be like a
derivative like what if I told you to
speaker
that's my favorite line do what you say
so yeah read that comic you can learn
about you guy if I had to pick one line
from d1 it would be sure what is it it's
Oh get your orb off my map or whatever
it is it's when Cades talking to oh yeah
her yeah when she's got the orbs like
get your orb off my mouth whatever it is
just his tone and delivery on that when
it's always just really good but check
out the comic it's really cool can I
give some idea and you really actually
get to see how Cyrus kind of gets booted
out of the tower for just having more I
don't want to say a difference of
opinion but just the twist of words and
things like that it's like no so oh yeah
cool check it out I didn't see any like
Easter eggs
in there this time I haven't heard any
like patches or or any crazy like emblem
like laughs Holly a tie straight a
choice right yeah I didn't see anything
to [ __ ] or anything so we come to this
week and it is a lot to discuss the
patch went live on Tuesday plan they
said the rewards have been improved on
Wednesday the comic came out and then
right here on the screen is the big one
boom we've got a lot to discuss just get
into it
can you hear my dog I'm sure your dog is
ready like out across the street
she's the guard dog Huskies are not
guard dogs but apparently she will let
you know if somebody's walking across
the street or sneezing in some of their
house that's like what a salad is yeah
they're wolf stuff going on usually
don't howl that much but yeah they
occasionally get that soil of what a
road map is introduced 1.2 launched that
was masterworks that was the Raider
wards and all that other stuff so season
2 will include two more substantial
patches on the end of February in the
end of March so one point one point
three will as discussed previously
include nightfall scoring and high score
tracking so I don't know when crimson
days is actually gonna launch I mean
typically it's a Valentine's thing but
this patch it may be pushed back a
little bit yeah maybe it may be maybe
you got I'm thinking maybe the the
twenty if they might drop it I think it
maybe I don't know we're gonna patch it
to 27th right so yeah it's like they may
just have it in there and it's like hey
if honestly crimson days gets a little
delayed come on baby maybe they launched
maybe they launched day and date 127
maybe because they did it around
Valentine's before but if it's delayed
but it works I'm okay with it again I
take it yes absolutely no there's a lot
of work involved I would love to be a
fly on the wall in some of these not
just a leaked information just to see
the process in action you know yeah I'd
be really interesting to see like the
process the way the number of people
involved because I mean even for like my
wife's company she's a project product
manager and like just a different the
people I you up UX design and then the
development and all those pieces they go
through it's like man I just
let me see that hold of him one process
that somebody at the scale of bungee
that would be an absolutely absolutely
like I swear I don't want to tell
anybody anything I just want to see how
you guys work you sort of see the
process that's the thing yeah cool
so nightfall scoring and high score
tracking first piece let's go now this
is also when they mentioned the high
score is going to replace the timer
right which for me works well because
solo videos are gonna be something I
have no issue with finishing it but also
if I want to go through and show example
of hey this is where every crap what do
they call this week little glowy boxes
you shoot and I'm just blanking on the
name I'm like into you talking to
anomalies there we go
anomalies yes yes so if I want to take
my time go through strike and be like
hey here's this one take these guys out
here's a strategy for this room here's a
couple places to hide like I can take my
time and do that somebody like esoteric
hopefully if they have the scoring
options because they say they're
selectable e so when they said him
before he can just crank up everything
and probably blow through it just as
fast and get like the highest solo score
possible so more people have more
options but hopefully he can still show
his prowess of just kicking some butt
and being awesome so that dude's got
skills he's amongst absolutely so that
will be coming I'll be curious to see
how much they give the scoring like the
wait for either time if that's even a
factor if there's like benefits for
being faster I mean if it's just like if
I see a number at the end but I don't
have like you know a bounty or anything
or reward for doing a quicker you're not
gonna have as much incentive but it'll
kind of give a variance to certain
people still working on be like hey I
just want high score so and there's
tracking involved so you know if you
wear your emblem be like hey I got the
score you got proof absolutely that
would be cool yeah I'm excited about
that one I'm very excited I'm a huge
proponent of um of loss scoring strike
scoring and it kind of validates the
nightfall it makes you want to do it so
at first like I don't I don't at first
was like why isn't just indirect strikes
as well but um I do like him because I
feel right now I don't have that urge to
have to do the knife flopping literally
skipping in my falls and um now this
kind of this will definitely get me
amped and excited to do them yeah gives
you a little different reason different
way to play like you're going to hey I
want more person
shots and maybe different maybe there's
different modifiers per week it's like
hey if you want to turn on grenades this
week you can more grenade kills so we'll
see what they do but I'm kind of curious
emblem in aura we rework you wanna try
and tackle that one first yeah um I'm
curious about that I mean when I hear or
obviously I think the nightfall stuff um
you know a little the glowy joint over
our head we're gonna see you know how
that rocks um yeah I think for me
personally the emblems have to have a
little bit more functionality you know
just like stuff like Iron Man ER and
stuff like that just tracking more
tracking stuff you know I know they've
kind of teased did we know that um the
raid even though what is it the prestige
raid emblem does not even track raid
completions as it currently stands so
this is something that I feel just like
small low-quality life stuff that they
need to now I would like the aura to
really be cool like to really stand out
kind of like the one when you finished
at nightfall and you're like okay you
know so we'll see this I'm very curious
to see how they how they tackle that one
yeah I was like honestly if it would be
something I'd like to see it bit a
little more I know they say rework so
for one when you do the prestige raid
you ought to have something kind of
permanent that you can throw on because
the Presley's raid I know there's some
people who can hammer it out I see Mesa
Shan run it all the time because he's
got his crew and they've mastered it but
some of the things you have to do to do
the prestige are not easy and to get
like a random group to knock it out more
people probably do it now but it's not
an easy task for anyone if you knock it
out like that thing should last longer I
mean personally it should just be
something like if you've done it keep it
but I would also see like to see
something like the dusty 1 trials
emblems look like you're walking around
I want like giant glowy wings on my yes
a little more obvious as to what it is
and where you might get it so if you're
walking around for a little while you
look like that much more of about like
you got a really shine when you see this
more yeah you and the prestige nightfall
could be a less obvious one you do the
prestige raid and maybe like you know be
kind of crazy have some giant golden
crowns since
you know is all that and just you know
pleasure turns all have something very
ornate for this one and say maybe if you
do a different prestige later on you've
got a different aura that you can and
maybe you can actually change them out
so my because absolutely fire team
members on destination map pretty
straightforward but quality of life
should have been there for I think the
vision had this from like day one so way
to get on board yeah finally just you
know that's fine
PC public text chat this is honestly
just something PC should have had yeah
yeah it's just one of those general
things be its most social spaces in the
any PC game are gonna have that people
can't like type at the same time whether
you're driving around running somewhere
you want to take real quick is just
natural should be there so shout out to
Dugga Dugga from IG and fudge chad he's
like you know he's like so pissed off
that that was Sudhir so I know he'll be
happy about yeah I like I like him mono
fireteams yeah adds a nice perspective
definitely know from the last when he
said he's gonna be taking a break for a
while so we wouldn't see him for a
little while which I respect which I
respect so then we've got exotic
repetition reduction oh my gosh like I
know we said this before but like my
warlock has five of the same robe you
know I know I don't have all the exotics
on her him and then my hunter I had that
story last time where it's like I got I
was wearing the item I got two more
times within a couple of minutes I'm
like it feel as bad in destiny won and I
don't know if we just get exotics more
frequently now yeah like what the
feeling is but I never felt like I had
that much of or even if I did it didn't
feel as bad and I can't quite put my
finger on why yeah I still feel like I
would I wouldn't mind if exotic uh you
know Travis got toned I feel like it I
statics all the time like that's just me
you don't forget about the duplicates I
just feel like I get exotics all the
time and it's not the pool is not big
enough for me to be getting all these
exotics all time
it was like how masterworks is now I'll
be fine but I understand that I
understand the repetition part you know
I definitely your pain on it you know
just getting the same thing over and
over but no I'm with you like I mean
well see and that's what I would
honestly like is I know most people have
them and there may be something like a
taking king where you have like here's a
slew
brand new ones and please like at least
I know they're tipping more towards new
ones which is good but when they
introduce a slew of new ones like a full
new games worth very something like that
as you're saying make them harder to get
because right now I mean I'm hopefully
gonna have harder decisions to make but
yeah I want them harder to get
absolutely the matter more absolutely
Jesco companion mod shader interactions
I think that's just the app right
basically so it's app modification so if
you guys want to check out what a vendor
has you guys can check that stuff out on
your app as opposed to checking out my
weekly reset video either way I'll still
cover it for you guys but oh is it Isis
and then the lice at last asterisks and
these anything with an asterisk next to
it yellow may go to a later release if
they can't quite you know get them there
they're stretch goals so there's
something they're shooting for but they
may or may not get nightfall strike
unique rewards well let's go I'm gonna
let you jump into that one this is what
I'm talking about
asterisk or not um dude that is so
important to me like d1 just doing what
was it the other was at the fallen saber
strike whatever I think I remember
getting that you know warlock helmet
they were just so unique people are like
where did you get that from you know I
mean and at first again I wanted it to
be in heroic strikes but now that I look
at it the state of destiny - they
definitely need more incentive to do the
nightfall and ID now I'm starting to
come around he bought this I'm coming
around I'm putting it in the night for
now cuz I don't do the 94 hour behind
it's like I do my call to arms I'll do a
lot of stuff like this just do not
enough incentive for me to do it and now
you throw this in and you know they got
the metrics looking at you know knife
for completions and they probably seen
that go down so I'm coming around I just
this what I need though I just need I
just don't want to emblem no I mean it
better be like you know I'm trying to
think of a strike for example so take
the pain of the boat one on necess which
is my least favorite strike probably
ever by the way that boss fight is
ridiculous
but I mean for him if it's some Riddick
it's either say maybe it's a ridiculous
gun or maybe it's a maybe for some
reason you get an aura where you can
decide if you want to be kind of cloaked
oh so I mean just make him unique make
them specific and be like okay that
cloaked one has a ridiculous rate drop
it's not gonna change that enemies can
see you but if you look like you're
slightly cloak that would be kind of
Awesome I mean that'd be example but
give me something that looks like the
helmet maybe you know I mean yeah
exactly just some way to be like hey I
did the nightfall this week I got lucky
enough to get this drop looks pretty
cool and give it maybe like one little
perk give it a something extra to like
because armor as we were saying armor
needs a rework for it two men or more
it's like have that strike thing be like
hey maybe it's got one more mod maybe
it's got one more perk on it something
like that so it's even more of an
incentive and I think this also will
help at least a little bit for at least
the playerbase that's still around with
games if you give more incentive for
people to run it then hopefully they'll
be you know helping more or it's like if
me and my buddy want to go play on PC
and we need a third will be like a let's
search guided games even pick one I
think that'll be good as well so
absolutely pretty much wrap one point
one point three so it's as strikes and
social as the overall theme of that
which seems to make sense I agree
somewhere in their crimson days is
supposedly coming but we haven't heard
much on that so we'll know more when you
guys do absolutely all right one point
one point for let's go March 27th this
is my this is my segment this is the
sandbox in crucible kognito let's say
you can run this one down you take it oh
let's go sandbox and crucible baby and
this was probably the best thing I
worked I said it's the best thing I woke
up to when I saw the flop and I've seen
sandbox in crucible because up until
this point Yvonne says we haven't heard
anything about the sandbox just light
stuff
oh we're gonna dress it you know at a
later time but nothing specific so just
seeing this stuff oh man this to me
again I'm a firm believer that when
destiny is at its peak
you've got the content drops but at the
end of the day PvP is what keeps this
thing alive during the droughts you know
I mean when you've got a good crucible
sandbox when you've got a good trials of
Osiris you know I mean so um yeah man
when I seen these I was very excited so
let's get into let's get it to each one
start for the top all right so weapon
ability in sandbox changes and we've
actually got a decent discussion on that
down below so do you want to like save
that for when they break that down from
him so we will come back to that put a
pin in it
it's a big pin but we will get back to
so heroic strike modifiers now as we've
said a couple times this should have
been there when they launched with or
whatever it was they should have been
there so I'm glad they're bringing it
back I mean nightfalls already have them
hopefully Brett they bring back some
more modifiers as well mix it up you
know so I'm totally down with that now
there's no strike scoring in there they
don't mention anything like that it'd be
nice to see that even if it's just kind
of fun for practice but competitive they
need that uhm so even if it's for
practice for the night ball for a
different you know playlist whatever is
going their jump in see which one of us
be like alright let's see if we can do
this no crucible we got iron banner 6v6
whoa huge you know huge and I have a
personal story about this too okay shout
at the gaming addict in the chat static
about it um III 2017 d2 announced you
know it's on the floor and I see my man
Luger and I rolled that for them and at
that time we knew nothing about anything
you know just about the crucible all we
did was fall before they were kind of
like getting in and then um basically
you know we started talking to him and I
said look man is there any chances I
mean even for iron banner you know I'm
saying you know on sixes and um he's
like you know what I have nothing to
comment at this time maybe with the
Piazza at this time
but oh yeah you're there so it was
definitely something I was holding out
hope and this is so key because the
problem with destiny - big time is this
just disconnect you know I'm saying like
shot the gaming addict he's like give me
a meter I got he was because he was with
me when I got you a little late don't
worry I got you cuz he wants to talk
about the story um yeah like the thing
about destiny - right now is that the
raid is the only six player activity now
back in d1 you didn't have to break up
your squad you know I mean like you did
like if we went from the raid we went
from iron banner we stood like this
splitting off people it is sad like I
have clan mates now and it's like we're
gonna run anybody before so yeah oh no I
was just gonna say but it's like that
should be like I they're being patrols
like I'll have like raids patrols
crucible if you have an option for six
make an option that you can I mean if
you only have four it's fine for a
smaller playlist but if you have an
activity that six and be like hey you
guys want to go tear it up and necess
for a little while not get our
flashpoint all six of you can go do it I
mean you have enough people follow on
public events now that they're not
really difficult anyway maybe crank up a
difficulty or something if you laugh six
more in there and make actual social
spaces a bit of a fight where I can't
just like walk around and not fire and
not die yeah I mean it's like I mean you
do see videos people like I can walk
through the story pretty much skip most
things shoot the important guy and move
on like you know make the social spaces
have a different difficulty division
figured that at a point in I mean they
got to a point where like hey the
overall world now that you've completed
the story you can crank it up a level
right I mean how's that as an option if
you have six in there but now I'd love
to see sixty six and six is for iron
banner it'd be a nice way to set it
apart as we yes that uniqueness right
yep I mean some way to make iron banner
everything besides just you know green
crucible okay we got another hand cannon
and like the stats on it are decent mhm
you know it's a slug shotgun so it's one
of those but it's still just that like
tan and green gold emblem it's just a
different color for crucible like if I
in banners you're 66 that comes back
all right yeah so absolutely absolutely
I like it
that means you I did it Regis it makes
it a prestige kind of event right now
I'm curious to see how they handle will
they have a playlist that that also has
sixes you know like how's that gonna
work I mean I listen I love that it's
coming flying back don't get me wrong
but lying around all the time
yeah is it just gonna go away now
complete when I invent agos it's that
expression so I'm very curious to see
how to implement that as well so and
that may lead into the next point is
weekly crucible playlists including
mayhem listened whoa liked it we're
gonna take it away and be like hey
rotating crucible playlist just like you
did before
you can have your you know quick plays
and your competitive but I have that one
mode that rotates and have mayhem and
they're like every other week for all I
care but absolutely maybe that's just
like maybe it's you know normally it's
fours but maybe the rotating playlist
might be a six or something else so and
the vibe I'm getting from this advances
is that see that was part of the things
that made me love d1 as a crucible
player like you jump day remember you
did you daily crucible you had your
weekly crucible right and then on the
weekend you had your trials and and you
had your um your true meaning of war
bounty from Shaq's that gave you night
for level rewards right yeah like as a
crucible guy and I'm don't even I'm not
like one of the best crews were play but
I love d1 sandbox crucible like I had so
many activities to do that I didn't have
to touch PvE for a while and again these
are the things that are the lifeblood
these are the things that keep destiny
going you know I mean during the dry
spells a good sandbox someway somehow I
mean something more than either
milestones or daily challenges or
someway it's like so the way they've got
the emblems right now for iron banner
it's like you've got to do five daily
challenges they hit that emblem have
some way is something that you can track
and be like hey you can get your
nightfall tea or in Graham if you know
within a week you finish you know five
or six daily challenge just like you're
in there every week and that's a way for
you to get your nightfall towards and
multiple other things that might have
like four or five requirements but you
know something that you can grind for in
PvP
still if you would be alternative if say
you know the nightfall may still be a
struggle or finding people whatever in
Italy because that that you just nailed
it you just nail it that was on like a
lot of times the crucible served as that
medium that when your squads not on or
you don't have a full fireteam it was
still activities you can do as a solo
player as a solo player now yeah I can
do a couple public events those are fun
there get me wrong but like d1 crew the
d2 crucible
yeah and I think with that also goes
they've got to figure out something with
the matchmaking allows like overwatch
it's like if you have six people in a
match there's a team of four in a team
of two you're paired up with the same
thing solo ship fights all those teams
by teams like that has that I will wait
longer for that type of match like I
don't think anybody would probably say
well you wait you know three or four
more minutes for a match that's like
proper yeah you're gonna enjoy each one
more and have the downtime you know
maybe go check something else whatever
it is but that matchmaking for teams has
got to get fixed that's absolutely
absolutely
so crucible ammo and gameplay tuning
pretty big it's vague I'm gonna tackle
it I think the way the vibe I'm getting
is okay I don't think my gut my gut
doesn't say like primary ammo cuz you
know obviously we don't never run out of
it you know so I'm gonna go with like
maybe like heavy weapon ammo maybe
that's possible you know I'm gonna I'm
gonna cause really I don't look at it as
a big issue in d2 crystal that's just me
you know yes no right and PvP exactly
you've nailed it in PvP I don't see you
know any issue so gameplay tuning I just
look at this is basic sandbox stuff
maybe looking at like arm for example
like how many you arm get of our fusion
shots you know maybe increase the amount
of arm ammo you know in you know with
with certain specific weapon types
that's what I'm kind of seeing that's
what I'm feeling like when I see this
little number bullets in a hand cannon
and yes heavy ammo
either be it drops or number or
frequency and all that stuff I think
some of that's listed below
so right absolutely we'll get to that
nightfall challenge cards this is new
yeah I don't know what that is 10 foil
hats can come out like what do you think
challenge cards all right let's break it
down
so we complete the nightfall we get 9
throw with rewards um well see when I
have a challenge I was thinking Tyra but
timers gone now at that point right so
what could we be challenging this is
nobody's lost the word cards like we
don't have a card anywhere in destiny 2
we had grimoire cards in d1 all over the
place but they don't exist so these are
I don't know if it's that's a weird
phrasing to me I mean a challenge like
some of them the nightfall it's like
okay so if you're going through one of
the new mercury strikes to say the
nightfall the one with the rotating
Hydra basically the top of me with one
that is there is one of the challenges
when you have that as a night falls the
fact that you have to kill the I'm
blinking on their damn names
minotaurs kill the minotaurs within 90
seconds or something like that
if that's one of those things that's now
like trackable either to go through and
do all of those things maybe you get
like it might fall other award I don't I
don't know I was like those are the only
challenges in the nightfall but a
challenge card I am so so yeah they're
gonna have to clarify that one a little
later but yeah you can make all the
stuff up you want do you guys have any
ideas out there and chatter and comments
leave that stuff below I'm real curious
out the cop out so he actually mentioned
um what the crucible bet to back up when
a crucible thing he was mentioning that
they also got to do something about
jumping into a losing match you know
three times about what a man stuff like
that but as far as this nightfall car
challenge cause what is that does that
game that it can build it Oh Mike's
levels is good I see a mini oh yeah yeah
you sound better does sound fine you
sound about that iron banner 66 is that
way with Luigi 600 so play try to expect
me on my phones
okay thank you for testing does this
sound fine though um doesn't sound as
good as normal you know saying that
that's because the the mic I normally
talk on on YouTube it's made for podcast
okay guys you know you sound you sound
solid alright but yeah I was like I
think the other ones notice will be
better okay sound like you guys do on a
normal occasion okay yeah this leads
into the next one what you were saying
is crucible quitter penalties so an
incentive not to have games they're like
two or three people down or starting
over and yeah it's ridiculous
um penalty for that or quitting timeout
just instead of just play through your
match even if you're losing just you
know take that time to work on a
challenge or whatever it may be so
hopefully they'll work on some incentive
for that like if you quit a match you
got a cool-down or if you do it twice
like I don't know I just hate losing end
of you know someone drops the match you
know and then like you just force to
play it a man down I've seen it in
trials I've seen it too many times is
demoralizing I've been on a squad where
the whole team's quit on it and it's
like just me versus for like I've done
that too actually
so that's what you usually start dancing
and see if they'll actually just mess
with you sometimes they'll do that and
then somebody's like alright fire rocket
at your feet which is fine but it's like
on that point I'll just like dance cuz
it sucks for them too because they only
have one person to kill and it takes
them longer to finish the match that
normally have a reasonable amount of
time so yeah needs fixed on both side
wait a minute [ __ ] I got a point to chat
he says wait he said the challenge card
could be the book from d1 like a record
book coming back possible yeah some
variation of that but maybe maybe you'd
like a little nightfall book and there's
certain things you have to do for your
strikes and you can work on completing I
mean I'd love to see record books come
back in any way shape fashion or form
whether it's you know destiny 22.0 and
that's a record book that you're gonna
finish up before we roll into that one
like they did before maybe this is a
piece of that but we'll see and then we
got repeat crucible map and strike
protection so just repeating maps
that'll be
a little more variety always good and
then the one that I seem to want to
explode on previously exotic weapon and
armor sandbox changes so this is my
sandbox thing that I want yes yes
huge huge I think um I've been screaming
that from d1 I don't feel that a Bungie
does that enough I honestly feel that
they have exotics they like they pump
out exotics a lot but they never go back
and rework not that they never do it but
it's seldom that they go back and buff
and rework ineffective exotics yeah I
mean absolutely you've got a player base
of I mean started a million's it's not
there now what I mean still you've got a
lot bigger player base to fill out how
things feel which ones are used and be
like okay so these are the common ones
that are used how can we take this one
and bump it up and I'm alright like I
want a base level of all exotics to be
above what the best one is now I want
them to cuz all of them now as many
people have said you can run a full load
out of Legendary's and you don't feel
like you're missing anything this master
works down so I mean master better
Devils like you find me a better gun
than that out of exotic and then we'll
talk but I don't think there is one so
now you guys are talking like peer like
speculation and like this is a foreign
language to me right now cuz I've no
clue what you guys are talking about
look at the develop it ro Batman they'd
be March 27th there's a lot of stuff
going down bro it's a lot of stuff for
the sandbox
I understand that they're making a lot
of changes in the Destiny community
right now but I can't really justify
being really height for something that I
saw that and like oh they're adding is
[ __ ] that's been in Destiny's before oh
absolutely but my thing is you rather
them not do anything what's not that I
can't justify being really excited for
something that I played in destiny one
like know obviously destiny to four it's
not them brewing up a roadmap to fix the
game that they they made changes for now
they're like oh let me it's it's like
that meme where they're like you know
the you know that meme where it's like
talking about the people who who
it's a really bad meme i really
shouldn't bring it up
it's like bungee is that is that player
right and then you know they they drop
they drop all the people that they they
go to for that one and it turns out that
chicks a bad chick they're like oh I
talk to all these people it's like
bloody that person but hardcore bass and
now they don't know what to do and
they've had to go back and refix
everything the way that the hard court
wanted it and it's like look like it's
like I was telling a walker yesterday
it's like what I can't you know he was
saying that's news trash you know that
to palooka Gators but uh look I can't
see here and say destiny to trash right
it's just they went towards the
direction that I'm not okay listen you
know which a lot yeah I'm saying that
see some I gotta see some rate stuff
like on the rate dude I understand that
and here's the hitting you for you right
now as the raid guy these might not be
feet I'll be I'll be completely honest
like these might not be few but as as
the pvp guy which is a lot of people
like the pvp community is actually to be
honest with you and it is more neglected
than you guys so for them for this this
is huge for the pvp guys cuz those are
guys are playing trials every week
crucible every day they had nothing to
look forward to now as far as um you
know your stuff I would say probably
like that season 3 when we get into that
there's probably gonna be when it's a
little bit more safe for you but right
now I understand your point there's
nothing for you as a raid guy outside of
prestige rewards
I feel perceive more than great mods
right like that could put that and like
I saw that you know they're doing some
work kind of rewards when it comes to to
the right it's like what you're
literally putting rewards that wasn't
destiny one so like really excited about
that
it's I am
destiny ones raise anyway so it's like
okay so you gonna make me play you know
you know okay race to trash raids and
get ain't get equipment that I had in
deaths anyone it's like it you know
equipment built around a destined was
like you're fixing the rewards when
that's not my issue so what is your ego
what is you what do you need to see the
mechanics are putting in raids right now
I feel like they're too casual I'm not
enjoying them I write your anything is
raised ling'er you are not a fan of
railay you like to Leviathan the first
one but raid layer your we mean you
argued a few times over the the
Leviathan I was like okay you know it's
cool for an opening I did enjoy playing
it but I wasn't exactly impressed with
how it wasn't hard how many after we got
really into the found out for loops than
everything it's like you know it's like
well-oiled machine it was like I was
currently it's like the boss I felt like
the boss was the best part of the whole
raid you know they're in the dog save
this discussion for those eggs we got a
lot of points to cover but the whole I
understand your point I still I disagree
i think that the LaVon listen I'm not
gonna say Leviathan was the best rate
ever but it was a good it was a solid
rate I do agree with you on raid layers
they feel little casual eyes they
definitely feel not as hard core
mechanics that what a raid but what
people who play arrays are used to but
um we got some points to get into I can
tear up my baby boxes right now but I'll
feel you attic that you know what you
represent a lot of the community that is
still like hey this is not enough you
know and I respect that
so what our job with flash point is to
let you know what is safe to dip your
foot back in me they come out there
because right now it's looking like to
be completely honest with you they are
calling me already bought the second and
you're the second one of those people
that's like oh I bought it I'm not gonna
even try
no [ __ ] together they do I keep playing
they [ __ ] together what am i plain
monster honor what should I have I feel
you I feel you bro
Lord Montes let's get back into the
paddock so no we're just saying but yeah
exotics just need I want them more
powerful and the things we've discussed
that before just owned exotics to be
exotic as they should live up to their
names so hopefully that is what shameful
thing yeah break another bro your mic is
terrible no it's because I was a I was
rotating I was getting my badge off of
work my face was cutting in and out be a
voice and not gonna have to drive wrong
it's it's really bad we got some stuff
to finish up daddy buster
alright so that will pretty much wrap up
season 2 so I mean that'll be March 27th
- whenever season three starts then
we're gonna go into season 3 which
they're saying right now May which
honestly if it was May or June if I and
just take the time you need to make this
stuff right this is also gonna be time
for they said it should be day and date
with the second expansion I saw
something on Twitter Chris Rivera
clarified that season 3 should also be
the new season the new expansion I think
this stuff is gonna be coming together
with that so that's nice to see so first
we've got eater of worlds prestige vote
I kind of wonder if like I know they're
working on prestige and difficulty
numbers because the LIFO right now it's
only three hundred thirty thirty right
look trying to figure the way they want
to work some of that stuff out and maybe
they'll just have more clarification
later so they're waiting for that but it
just seems a long time to get a prestige
mode so yeah he actually uh Christopher
Barrett made a comma so one tweeted at
him as to say like why are they
addressing the prestige mode at the time
of season 3 and they did say they're
gonna I thought that this up the table
they were gonna actually get into that
why but they didn't seem to touch it but
um this apparently there's there's
supposed to be some reason as to why
they're gonna do drop a prestige mode so
late
yeah who's like I didn't see that one
yet but I mean it would make sense
because I think right now they're trying
to figure out because when curse of
Osiris came out they locked people out
of content obviously they didn't want
that happened and they've got to figure
out whether they're just gonna keep
adding a new difficulty level each time
so you don't log people out of content
like let me just take people and bump
them up to say three thirty wins the new
expansion comes out and say it's 360 or
350 or whatever and then you know you're
either your prestige mode is still gonna
be the elite stuff so you can play the
normal raid the raid layer whatever it
is but then the prestige you for sure
have to have the expansion who knows but
yeah I mean it does seem like it's a
long time to get there so but I mean if
P if they're worried about like you can
play a raid right now and the
prestigious isn't there then hey I mean
honestly it's just it may take time for
them this just may not be that big of a
priority with everything else they've
got I can understand why you know a
difficulty on the smaller raid may not
be the biggest thing cell right
absolutely
seasonal crucible rankings so your
crucible man right here so they
discussed before we had two different
types he had glory and then you had
valid one which was just the more you
play the higher the numbers gonna get so
if you live in crucible you're gonna
probably have a really high number glory
was the one that is an actual rank now
this is the start of stepping into ranks
but if you win it goes up if your loser
goes down so you think I love this I
love this into me this is Bungie getting
back to their roots of Halo and I
remember I thought that their ranking
system was one of the coolest things you
know I'm as far as like you know you win
and you would go up and also if you lose
you'd go down so it kind of gives you
that persistent ranking that feel of um
of what you're doing and I love stuff
like that again
crucible man give us give us diehard
something to strive for to look forward
to and it's also you know the
competitive community they've been
screaming for stuff like this and I
really hope that this is the
differentiator between quick play and
hardcore right competitive like this
needs to be like but when you do
competitive maybe that's when this stuff
is kind of you know I've got the one
that actually goes up and goes down I
don't know if it's Valor Afghan law yeah
like maybe glory is specific to
you know valor or whatever got is
universal but I love stuff like this
this is what the backbone crucible
community needs love it yeah I mean
maybe if it's one of those where say if
you equipped the glory emblem you're
gonna be a much more of a skill based
matchmaking setup yes takes you longer
to get into a match and then say if you
equip the Valor one or if you just don't
have that one on you mean connection
connection based and that's fine I know
it's one more check and I'm not saying
that's an easy thing to program sound
simple when I say it but it's not an
easy thing to program but if that's a
way to say hey we're going straight up
skill on this one if my glory number is
one two seven four and I'm hitting
people like within ten or twenty right
around me then at least I feel like
especially if I played enough that I'm
gonna get a fair match and it takes me a
little longer to get there that's fine
vault space increase a little bit this
is I think my guess this is probably the
band-aid of 50 I don't know if there's
gonna be the overall fix I know they're
working on it they said they'll work on
something bigger if they can get it in
by then sweet there's a lot of pieces to
of all space increase shader fixes and
mods and there's a lot of other pieces
the one thing I haven't said well I
guess we're getting down to it because
that's at the bottom and this one's also
footmen take that one out yeah skipped
over private matches but honestly for me
that's mostly just for tournament play
like there's not that much there to me
so it's nice to play like a custom one
but I want to see like I want us to be
able to make playlists of crazy matches
as we said before like snipers and
sidearms and mayhem to the max or
whatever so until private match is
turned into that I don't know if I've
really ever played one so we'll see
multi email wheel again so like you give
us like how countless number of emotes
and I can only equip one it's so stupid
yeah at least yep
exotic master works this one is very
important based on the previous one you
got to make exotics worth while before
I'm gonna give up a masterwork like
better Devils to go use an exotic
something else now if you give me an
exotic
mitt a multi-tool and I can start
popping heads off with that thing yeah
you know then we're talking but you
see but ya exotics have to get better
for masterworks to matter Sal happening
you can put master works on them or all
of the like current exotics and I still
don't think you would change what people
would use so I agree they've got I'm
very curious to see how they tackle that
because that's a big deal you know right
now like you said you know I'm gonna say
they're phased out but this is not that
urgency that need to have to equip them
based on max work and then even more now
with Mesirow karma somebody gets a set
and they like running arts trader or
striker you're not gonna give you know
you're giving up a damage reduction for
that super so slacks yeah so I mean
those exotics really really have got to
get bumped I mean they're so afraid of
the balance yeah and it's like and and I
don't say it's an easy thing to balance
like I mean Blizzard is one of the best
people that balance balancing games but
it's not an easy task to do so I mean I
understand the balance but you know go
through exotics make them all crazy and
I mean you can go back and tweak them
later cuz they can release patches
fairly quick if they want to do a hotfix
but I mean make some stuff crazy it's
like I want exotics to really be like
hey if you're using that gun well I'm
using this one you might beat me
sometimes I might beat you or whatever
but yeah they should I want some rock
paper scissors of stuff going on where
it really makes a difference
oh absolutely seasonal vendor
progression so like that face yeah I was
like I mean think it's just like during
each season the more it gives you just
some incentive to keep playing and all
of these things hopefully are reasons to
come back I mean what seasonal Thunder
progression get me in the game right now
probably not that probably not but if
it's part of something cool later on
just a little more incent to play a
little longer for some things then cool
when I when I see that I think um Dee
Warren um remember when you were part of
a faction and you got that faction to
like level 25 and then they gave you you
know me I don't know maybe something in
that rewards like you know based on your
consistency with a specific vendor maybe
it's tied to a level maybe it's tied to
a reward so was it well I think devran
Kay is gonna be the busiest one because
everybody does everything on eid easy if
they don't have to do anything else yeah
yeah I think he's gonna he's gonna be
king Sal but yeah I mean I think that'd
be really cool so say it's like you get
you know you're tracking for an ever mom
to like level 20 or 25 you can be like
hey I'm gonna go get exotic maybe even
if it's just a cosmetic it's just a
little more of like if I'm grinding ebz
all the time I got something cool out of
it so I'm kind of kind of like to see
that affection Rayleigh improvements I
mean I'm not sure exactly by what means
I love I'll okie love faction rally um
just a concept of it so you know
anything you know anything that you can
do to really promote that thing I mean I
forgot which podcast I was listening to
and maybe maybe it's fire teen chat and
you know maybe something to the effect
like you know you go on patrols and you
know you're actually seeing people with
the faction and law on them or something
to that effect where it's like it's more
of a competitive thing out in a social
space or even in the crucible they can
kind of have like a you know just
something that really gets you behind
that pledge right there that they want
you to pledge and make that commitment
so just create that you know that's a
memory like it was like I can see I know
they have a limited number of weapons
but I was like you can do infection
early every week for all I care like
that's your things to do like it doesn't
have to be twice a season I mean it
feels like some of the stuff that's too
far keep that I create all the time
maybe it'll edge once then you're
actually you gotta commit and like say
if you don't get it then you can't buy
that other teams love me and again
there's I think they're always afraid of
like locking people out of stuff be like
hey you picked the wrong faction you
don't get the gun this month well get
more insane whoops um but on especially
if it's like crucible and you're saying
if like if I'm running a new monarchy
because I want to look crazy ornate and
somebody else that there's got dead
orbit stuff I'm gonna be hunting the
dead orbit guy on the other team down a
hell of a lot more than I am the new
monarchy guy like I might it might give
me an Sun we go track somebody else so
yeah they could they could mix it up a
lot so I just hope it's not like
factional improvements it's just easier
to get the faction really stuff it's
like no I want like systems need
overhauled I have like so many things
need to matter more I think that's the
biggest way to say it I agree and then
the last one this is what I put my foot
both earlier for mod system improvements
I like to hit this I liked it as I want
to see what was this this is like the
rate mods are nice leg I think there's a
couple that are kind of lackluster but
overall I mean a mod that you can put on
your cloak that gives you 25% bonus
damage when you know you got a celestial
night hook just like tearing it up on
Calais now that's when stuff starts to
matter and and and take different mean
you get a legendary mod okay make it or
you can get like a masterwork Ahmad take
that you know take a normal one that you
get from whatever you're doing and crank
it up a notch like you can get
masterwork mods or exotic buds or I want
more Lots variation things that matter I
mean that's my poorly spoken those like
I mean you can probably say it better if
you want to right now but I know I'm a
lot more of everything yeah I just want
more diversity in those mods you know
you know just more things man more MORE
you know um d1 kind of stuff I remember
you know remember when you had um
specific my perks and stuff for iron
banner sprint speed on you know was
increased when you on a respawn or just
little things like that you know I mean
like just yeah just keep on with it man
keep because all at the end of the day
it promotes individuality you know I
mean and you feel like your character is
different your guns are different your
armor is different you don't want to
have that's the problem with you too
because with the fixed roles everything
is kind of saying no I mean I'd love to
see be like hey you got a range mod for
auto rifles be like okay so we go
something like that for mod for skyrim
pools I mean I can pick the high points
on most of them like impact on my hand
can have that thing hits you like a
truck I mean do it or like stats can
change too if you get a lot for I mean
master armor is different but yeah mods
deed needs some help and then for you I
guess for weapons sorry is that sound
better much better much better
yep I'll continue but eyes for for
interrupting the part I don't think it's
my mic I think it was my phone
connection okay you tell you but this we
finishing up the real man yeah yeah
so I mean mod systems just I mean and
this is what they've said
they are really trying to make them
impact more and make your player feel
more powerful get back to the point of
regarding feeling you know to that godly
status casually and as you said in
devout individuality is also a huge
piece like we don't want everybody to be
cookie cutters from the random role as
well as anyone's been cried for that
thing make it awaits where you know if
everybody gets the same gun you put
different mods in and you can play a
different way than I can so you know I'm
totally down for that so that's that's
what all those big pieces at the end
nightfall strike rewards' exotic sandbox
changes and mod systems those are all
things that could slip into later
releases but those are big fixes so
we'll be hopeful and see what happens
absolutely let's get into it so next
people I love toys since and people I'm
like I want a single file to hide the
numbers let's go
alright so Josh Hamrick talks about the
sandbox so has Co more hype about baby
let's go they want to limp some context
he said they're working on lots of
updates over dusty - there's gonna be
many of these discussions over the next
couple of months as we get closer and
closer to a big sandbox update and
there's probably gonna be hopefully more
updates but at least they can say what
they're working on um in different
people will have different focuses like
he may be the overall somebody maybe
focus on crucible and there could be
differences and you know crucible rate
PvE sandbox all that stuff so they've
testing a series of changes right now
and they're basically calling it their
go fast update um basically they're
adding more speed more mobility ability
to recharge time all of that stuff is
going to be faster pace of the overall
game should improve especially the super
spy like that he mentioned increasing
the amount that is one of my most angry
things I had about the crucible is like
it takes so long to get my super you
finally get it
everybody has it when you have it you
use it once and it's over that's it like
things like you whenever I hit
multiplayer you only like get it a max
or twice maybe you maybe don't even get
it to like PvP than you - OH
oh yes humble lord addict here continue
things they want to hit so I mean they
want supers faster so you can demolish
your enemy's frequency all that stuff so
first point is all three glides plus
catapult and strafe lifts have been
retuned and buff to make them more
unique and faster so you're changing the
way your characters move which is cool
like which is a feel fairly say me right
now but also just yeah it's like have a
jump Beast noticeably higher have a
glide be farther and faster I mean again
just like everything else make the
decision between those type of jumps I
could benefit each of them I got one
point though if they're gonna do this
with the jumps they have to increase in
air accuracy and that's because it seems
like that's been nerfed like it makes no
sense for me to run dawn blade was it a
2 min of the sky the one where you where
to win like that's the only like it is
really no incentive for me to play that
class like you should reward people who
want to be agile mobile move in the air
do all that stuff you know I'm saying
like so they've got it hit that hole I'm
assuming they will but they've got it
that if they did it I mean say in the
air it's like you have you know either
increased accuracy but probably
everybody should if you jump in the air
it's like or guardians we're still meant
to be pretty epic so either don't make
it terrible but hey if you're floating
in the air also give you a shield make
you harder to kill it they'll for
whatever I mean so I was like so the
mobility this is one that I was like I
don't matter you that's me
we told my buddies last week and
completely retune as well in short
everyone gets faster and the high end is
higher that lasts a little bit the high
end is higher I want so this is a point
where mobility may actually be a factor
now so that's huge because if you're
gonna yeah if you're gonna put in
masterwork armor and you're gonna let us
reroll the stats and all people are
gonna roll him to his resilience and in
recovery mobility was useless you know
now it can't be just strafe speed it's
gotta be I move faster than you because
my mobility is higher than you that's a
huge huge run faster straight faster
honestly be cool if something like
mobility and this would be interesting
say there were like little animations
were quicker because they cover that
below
just everything you were just a little
snappier on everything even it was just
a little bit so let's see the Blair the
players ground speed cap has been
increased so the cap is higher allowing
for faster total movement speed
regardless of how you may get there
whether it's via super the mobility sad
I guess there might be mods or something
like that so all of those things have a
chance to get you higher so maybe you
have a mod instead of your mobility so
that may be a way to balance some of
that stuff out we've got Ark Strider
Sentinel and striker roaming supers all
move faster and at the same speed as one
another while and they're super so
that's kind of cool and the art started
to go into even more so there's arc
spider as a whole is performing well in
PvP but mostly due to its neutral game
perks we made the following changes in
an effort to get this super to be more
competitive
faster animations both on attack and
dodge and increased range of attacks
which I'm fine with that like if you can
do that flying dodge you said that was
hard to hit and yeah that covers more
ground than paw that makes you a lot
more viable especially like oh crap you
see one coming at you like after all
that changes then hopefully you're you
know if your dodge is like back and
forth you a little bit more zippy it's
like you're gonna be harder to kill
so yeah you know I feel like arch I mean
hunters I feel like definitely you're
squishy but that's definitely nice help
yeah supers recharge faster for everyone
say it again say it faster for everyone
yes let's go crucible fun
supers like why are we so scared to let
us get our super is warning oh this is
what I'm talking about
oh this is all for me absolutely the
buff several weapon types including but
not limited to hand cannons pulse rifle
sniper rifles and shotguns a few
specific perks to make shotguns sniper
rifles infusions feel more prevalent cuz
they're not that common everybody uses
rocket launchers right unfortunately
I've seen nothing about grenade
launchers and they're like maybe we
should yeah good point I use a number
negligence as I said I've also been
working side by side with PvP to
increase the pace of PvP which is good
hopefully that's time to kill as well so
the team shooting kind of goes away and
the frequency of power play so
players respond faster for all quick
play modes our interest is on timers for
quick play have been reduced by 30%
so palermo coming up more frequently
which see this is where i was like it
was wondering at the time I don't want
it just to be a rocket fest I don't
think not that much but you're taking a
minute and bringing it down to like 40
you know 40 seconds or somewhere in
there so if you're you know depending on
how you're roaming with your team if you
have somebody on either side that's just
just hanging back and you're kind of
working again keeps picking up a rocket
that's jewelry I'm concerned about this
I am concerned they're going a little
heavy-handed with the power ammo stuff
and I get it but continue I got there's
another one underneath I want to get to
power mo respawn timers and survivals
40% which I mean already if you if you
aren't the clash in survival or
basically any of the competitive modes
if you're not at that main clash and you
run up for power ammo and it's coming up
that much quicker then yeah and then
same with countdown is 25% because you
have to all the point but run for all
those it's like you're getting power mo
into the mix a lot sooner which I'm okay
with but also I know they said supers
recharge faster I want all abilities in
there a little bit more bright mean it's
they have a tough line to walk because I
mean nobody wants to get back to sticky
grenades well nobody quality whatever
stick you right right but in turn it's
like if your supers are faster but your
abilities are slower then everybody just
could have run around with rockets and
you know I guess snipers would be
somewhat of a counter to that but yeah
shotgun still may have some work I'm
okay this is a weird one ammo counts
have been adjusted in relation to these
timers and in relation to the weapon
type I like that so I mean you get if
you get them faster you still most of
the time you get one sometimes we'll get
two Rockets but if you rock it and you
get them a lot faster you're still gonna
have them frequently that's true yes
your to I mean but if snipers do you get
like 10 shots
I mean snipers need to love fusions need
to love yeah
is it more shots do you tweak them so
they're a little more
I mean fusions are a little more
accurate but you've got to lead them
snipers like what if you picked up
sniper knows a one shot body those will
be used all the time I bet yeah so I
mean so there's a lot of ways they can
do that but I just kind of worry
any players drop their our mo on death
is it Oh boom that's the one I am my own
because remember when mayhem
they was implementing that during mayhem
I believe during dawning I like that
because in my opinion if you kill
someone with heavy ammo that's skill you
should be rewarded with the power MOC I
don't really care about necessarily the
respawn time as being faster to me this
is the change I like and I'm saying like
like it just it just it's it promotes
kill play and then at the same time you
know you reward you rewarding someone I
like that for some reason I really do
like that I remembered it it was
happening during mayhem and I was at all
what's this
it's a puzzle purple on the ground and
then it says the the drop break is
available to anyone so your team over
there so say like so many in fixham
power mo and then they walk out and get
their head picked off by a sniper maybe
you get up and be more useful with it so
the the only problem with that is then
you're using power mo even more and more
so just yeah if it drops it and then of
course somebody else is gonna have it so
then you run the risk of you know if
they walk out and get their head picked
off somebody at some point is gonna walk
out with a rock and shoot it at you even
if you die you've got a rocket coming at
you're sniping shot and then you're in
trouble so Power Animals seems like they
are gonna put it in there a lot more so
I'll be curious how that balances out
then we got a little bit more discussion
they said the shoulder charge changes
that went into a couple months ago have
been reverted so they said the movement
utility was perceived as a more valuable
than damage utility and unfortunately
shoulder charge is one of those things
when I get it to land and it hits and it
doesn't kill them I usually die late no
I mean the you or is it just me like no
I see it I see a lot whether you if I
just have it on I'm running around and I
hit somewhere if that the odds are my
animation of getting to them hitting
them and then the time for me to get
back up they're just sitting there
unloading an auto rifle the whole time
for me to get there and I'm dead so I
mean generally how I kill you Titans
one of those it's like okay so throwing
knife has ranging just throw it out me
and you can get a crit most of my
Health's down it's a couple hits yeah if
I get in there I mean if I have to get
in and that's why I was like shoulder
charge is one of those things that from
d1 yeah it sucked it was a one-shot kill
what if you pull your corners right it
wasn't as much of an issue so I mean
it's like I understand the reason is
it's like a Dodge but no no shoulder try
still just seems like it's too weak yeah
I'm so sad
so they said the goal of the untargeted
distance nerf was to discourage using it
as a movement mode by making an only
effective with enemies in retrospect we
think this change was a mistake and
we've heard you all say the same
esoteric put one thing up on Twitter
saying yes speedrun this is a way now is
it fair to all classes no but I mean
it's there so I guess it's one of those
things as long as the other classes get
some love in their Billie's I need so if
you're gonna have I mean everybody's
speed is going up but if the shoulder
charge can still cover that distance and
it doesn't now say it's like okay
instead of changing the distance what if
they nerfed it and said hey if you use
it and there's not an enemy there the
cooldown there's a lot of cool they're
quicker but there won't be a little
cooldown so you can't just spam it yeah
that's what I just don't want it to get
too crazy you gotta have a goal I agree
so I mean I think that'd be a way to
give them back the range if you want to
use it occasionally to make a crazy jump
or something like that but it's not a
way just spam it and cover like if I'm
running to another flag I'm just you
know charge charge charge like there's
gotta be some give-and-take they're
hungry now there's one line that I saw
like I forget who was on Twitter pointed
this out so Indian so what they say is
that we believe there are a number of
gameplay atoms like this that perform or
are used differently than we expected
but are thoroughly enjoyed nonetheless
in the future we want to embrace the
state of gameplay items like that and
balance around it not against it and
right that is a really nice statement to
see that they want to hopefully go to
the pot instead of nerfing maybe buffing
and yes little things that if they
intended it to be done one way but
everybody plays with in a different way
you know the community found a way to
use it okay work with the way the
community plays with it and then
you know as you said the hunters and the
warlocks and find a way to give them
something else right also by the way
please give the hunters more than a a
dodge yes please something else our
house continued but no I just wanna I
want to touch on that point you made a
good point because it's like and I like
to stay with me because at the end of
the day bungees balance and sandbox
history stuff has always been like nerf
into the ground and then sometimes
subconsciously it'll kill the entire
class of weapon grenade or whatever it
is because of that one thing and it's
like you said it's like yeah you can you
can you can recognize it but you can
also say okay how about we make this
other thing better in competitive you
know in competition to it as opposed to
just nerfing something in an entire
class into the ground in the past
yeah in the past it wasn't really like
you play what you want you play with the
hard [ __ ] nothing else yeah you know
it's just like they got they got a
people are having fun okay cool you know
if it's not obviously I wanted to get a
black [ __ ] like or not will remain
Thea's Lynn's broken obviously yeah we
ain't going talking broken you know
thorn d1 and Prometheus lens was the
only thing in be to that was really
broken out of hand
you know I'm saying but at the same time
like again not it's in a good place you
know you don't have to be so heavy
handing all the time so I like this
thing this is this is new from them oh
let's see and they said on one final
note that will be important to all the
snipers out there so abuse 9 person
listen up many of you rightfully
complain this numbers flinch is too hard
when taking its especially when as
they're now power weapons and you have
to make that decision to use them so
they dug into this and they found
somewhere along towards shipping to
again there's some bug that is
preventing us from being able to
successfully tune this now use the way
they've like so basically some way
somehow there's a bug that snipers torch
too much I don't know that's their way
to say it's a bug and they tuned it a
little too high and people don't agree
with it but whatever it is they you know
they're working on getting it better
they have to tune apparently snipers
individually to fix this mmm said that
it's going to take a while to stomp it
out and as they implement more in the
game there's probably even more to fix
but apparently that whole thing of you
know flinch on snipers is not meant to
be as much and right yeah this is this
is the whole
saying seeing what people think and
letting some of your public test the
game because just more people who play
games in different ways they're gonna
find things that you have however big
your pool is we're not gonna feel that
the whole game so like a public test
realm is still something that
potentially needs considered free stuff
like this and I want to I want to jump
into specifically specifically things
like it's actually talking now but um
yeah the thing is is like snipers right
and I am NOT a sniper that's the funny
thing you know they're just in a bad
place like you don't see them at all you
know and I get the flinch cart I
understand it they need if you get the
drop on a sniper and you shoot him you
know he shouldn't be quick scoping you
so fast and stuff like that but they
definitely have to do something with the
architect and I'm happy that they're
addressing as to why it's taking so long
old school Bungie you just don't hear
about it you're like you know what's up
when you're gonna buff sniper is when
you're gonna buff this and you don't
hear it now they say hey this is the
reason why and I'm saying again
transparency talk to you community this
is what we've been talking about you
know at least now I know what the issue
is and why they're struggling to fix it
I do I do feel like they're getting a
lot better at that transparency than
they used to be I feel like you know
they've always been really good at
listening to the community and reacting
he sometimes it's not as quick as people
would like but for the most part I feel
like they're not getting worse at that
they're getting better yes yeah
absolutely absolutely I mean it's it
feels it's weird but when they started
talking about this developer update so
like switch some person something some
discussion was said that hey you guys
we've got some issue it's like the
community is not happy somebody talked
to somebody it was like somebody
loosened the noose a little bit tell you
what's going on I saw them twitch
numbers I saw CDs number one saw pop G
oh you know all the fortnight to be
completely honest with you hmm
the original destiny really didn't have
the competition that destiny to has like
destiny had games that came out and had
a good
run but people went back to destiny like
this game
you guys got games like pub g9 now see
these like these games aren't like these
comes to the most like play all the time
addictive games I see what you're saying
and but remember we can't we can't
underestimate like even though what
happened in division you know eventually
but division was a force when they first
came the face was a 2d one division was
a true threat to them um obviously they
always gonna have to call of duty's to
battle and then I think my overwatch
came towards the end of the cycle too
which is you know good a good
competition all right but you're making
a good point Attica like I don't want to
get you are making a good point like
it's pop G now it's fortnight now
there's a lot of stuff they like so the
community right now the way I feel is
like they don't need to have patience
now cuz I okay you mess it up I'm gonna
go over here and play this and you got
to keep in mind that the majority of
these kind of gamers that would be
playing destiny to pub G and fortnight
would be like their bread and butter
like an EVP world like that's exactly
what they want to go do and that's like
the hot thing right now
so absolutely is going to be a battle
royale mode for honestly I like being
like somewhat insane but also kind of
Awesome I mean like it would be crazy to
see or even like what did they do so
they did battle royale did they do a 50
V 50 can you imagine that like and just
complete utter chaos like you got groups
and run this way you got like I mean
honestly like I don't think the service
could handle it Canada but if they could
I would love to see the chaos that would
ensue yes oh oh yes see that unlike a
closed Network where they could handle
it maybe I'm all about that foot patrol
I think I'll be chaotic as hell but all
about that for like some again men we
talk about the faction rally stuff like
if you support your faction you gotta in
its dead orbit do monarchy and whatever
they going in and going at it or
something like that but you know right
now let's let them focus on six
no just for theory I was like I could it
could be bananas but my only one that
doesn't want them to go back to sixes
like I'm hopeful 6v6 on like iron banner
and cells exactly I don't want them
going 66 on everything again literally
it's what you just said it's so far from
what the note said it's just I am banner
right now there's nothing else
indicating sixes in anything else so it
looks like it's literally what you just
said and I mean I would be okay that
they wanted to do like other playlists
with that yeah patrol playlist it just
made cuz control isn't more of a 656
anyway because it's kind of weird before
before my own okay with that you know
and you know to be honest with you I
used to be really really into trials of
Osiris and I'm just not like that with
this new one me at all like I want the
3v3 back for trial I literally - tweeted
at Chris Barrett and I just said not
only do I want exactly how it was at d1
I want the crazy psycho lure out of
there of the nine I want like you
brought Osiris back for a DLC give him
back control I love the Egyptian themes
I love like you know what I liked was
like like how it what's cool about iron
banner right now addict he's like Lord
Saladin's voice talking to you during it
and you know I'm saying like I love that
stuff like I wish that was we got d1
Osiris I mean travel Cyrus with Osiris
his voice the voice actor I'm in it put
us back on the lighthouse make it make
it make that make it relevant you know I
mean that's just me I'm not a fan to be
honest I'm not a fan of this 9 I'm not a
fan of that chick with the one sock
looking crazy
I'm not a fan I'm not a fan of her like
I'm gonna keep let I'm gonna go on my
rant it's a card you know I am NOT a fan
of trials of the 900 judgement no get
out of here I don't want you here please
bring back Osiris that is what we like
we like to Gyptian arm our moon rostov
Pharaoh looking stuff that's the hotness
my rant is complete
ah so I mean that's good like the
sandbox has got a lot of changes they
are communicating a lot more it's like
we understand why snipers are an issue
like the distance nerf it's like they
wanted to do it and they see how is
played so I mean just the idea that
they're seeing something they're gonna
remember the effect that they're
reversing changes they wanted to do like
these are all positive steps in the
communication as you guys are all saying
is more than we've probably ever had so
I'm loving that okay so the last piece
is just kind of patch issues and stuff
like that yeah as we said the issue of
the XP rank from 160 to 120 K and so
there was an issue with the API and
different amounts they're working on
getting that fixed so getting it closer
but you know parently a moving target
but they're getting there they mentioned
the shader previews there's an issue
with that right now lost sector throttle
yeah I've experienced that shade a
preview problem I have experienced AI
was I thought something I'm glad they
talked to ax I was like what is going on
I was trying to preview something that
was like three roles now and it kept
bringing me back to the top and like
what is going on so yeah that's an issue
yep lost sector throttling they said you
know from tenez the five minutes that's
gonna go into effect and they're doing a
hotfix for February for that and then
they said they're also gonna be making a
change to reduce you know a couple other
things and then finally they said
they're working on balancing crucible
experienced who couldn't be more in line
with everything else give it a little
bump which is nice I mean that pretty
well wraps up everything we've got for
the week there's no crazy description
down below that's like leading to
anything else they just said expansion
to will be coming it will have its own
raid layer so we know that's gonna be
coming in some way and honestly you take
I mean the raid Blair no it's not the
biggest thing and it's not a full raid
when we have and if you compare to
destiny one yes we got crota I mean so
many people that Kurt oh is broken
it could be honestly blown through
really quickly because you had the
sprint between lambs which was hectic
but kind of cool he had the bridge but
she really didn't how many boss fights
did you have to is unheard of basically
so if you get to raid layers within you
know the first year of destiny you're
gonna end up with about the same raid
content but I mean you know they're all
within a theme I ever heard the raid
lair fight is really really cool so I
mean d'argo sorry but this is where I'm
with addict and it's like I have to I
know he he came in and derailed us
with his raid his raid anger but our
feeling and the thing is that it's it
just feels like mini you know is like
raid light you know one or two slow
spaces and it just is such a disconnect
you know and I understand the concept of
why they did it and I think ultimately
just comes down through they can't put
out you know raids fast that's just not
there
I agree with that it's a hard it's
listen a raid I'm not gonna act like I'm
program a raid is definitely not an easy
thing to construct from a development
standpoint so it's just one of those
things I guess it's like they probably
look at it like well do we just you know
make them skip it or you know I'm saying
like you know do we do these little you
know value meal rates it's kind of like
if it's what we can get it's still
within the theme I mean or it's like ok
so if you didn't get any raid content at
all for curse of Osiris but you got a
brand new raid for expansion to would
you feel that that was better worthwhile
I mean but then you have to remember
somebody's doing something for whatever
comes either in September or what likely
will be poison I think at this point
would you'd rather have if the speed of
making her aid because I mean let's make
it you know design it and you've got the
art and then the fact that they've got
to test that thing to make sure it's not
broken because if they release a full
rate that's absolutely broken beyond all
belief like kurta was then you have any
other end of that so my main issue is
what I'm let out I just got a really you
know do you sure you want to go down
this road of artists it's this is this
is him this is his art i before you jump
in all I'm gonna say is what would I
agree with addict is that the major
mistake with this last one
eater of worlds it had nothing to do
with the curse of Osiris DLC right it
was it literally only did have nothing
to do with that they literally fought
the Cabal half the raid and then you
just get to the end it's like oh there's
a vex mind Lord here I don't know what
nothing about you know I agree with the
no I understand that I mean honestly you
have I mean you have the infinite forest
which is underused mercury as tiny so
just it was but yeah the disconnecting
the whole raid from the story to Calais
there's one adventure that tells you
about it and I understand kind of where
they went with that but no I understand
what you're saying all the sudden we
have a Beck's within the Leviathan wait
what happened yeah I understand that and
I think that's the part that annoys me
the most is it would be different they
had nothing to work with but they had
that force they could have made a raid
with and it's like they could have made
a really nice like time skipping raid
like uh you know when we first thought
we thought that you know the raid was
gonna be really remember that cutscene
that you go into the into the different
dimension and you see how you know earth
first attacked that one planet made a
mech stacked that one planet and made it
into a machine you saw the very
beginning of it like why couldn't we get
something like that visuals like that
something like that like I can't give
them a pass saying you know they didn't
have enough time because at the end of
the day it's like look like you gave us
a certain expectation the way you did
this then you want into the ranks and
then you changed it completely up you
didn't even mention anything like that
when we bought this and you can't tell
me that they didn't know that they're
gonna do the raid layers like they did
like if the raid layer is like three
rooms like how does it me that I took a
Fire's to a team we did it one time
Lord kaan you know how many times we die
maybe four times maybe and on top of
that the light level didn't I wasn't
even high I wasn't even break on it
that's some problem your destiny right
that's a problem and that that's the
that to me is the biggest part of the
sandbox and the gameplay and you know
updates that I'm still not seeing power
mattering you know there used to be a
time when you had to be you know 300
light or whatever that light level was
to even step foot and it legitly made a
difference you were getting wiped up you
know on the floor if you jumped in array
that way if in again people would
complain as far as the crucible aspect
like oh I didn't you know the
differences are negligible it it means
something to the hardcore you know get
that that advantage again not like they
were pub stomping people but it was kind
of a reward to say hey you've been
grinding your gear your light levels up
and you winning the trials and you win
an iron banner making sure you equip the
highest light level stuff I'd missed
that aspect of destiny
now it's just like I just thrown
whatever it doesn't matter if I'm you
know 300 that guy's 335 there's no
statistical advantage that guys we got
people on a climb that's never even beat
the right and they got four right here
oh well we not gonna be all ready we
don't get into that you know that's that
that far as I said we could push
Hawthorne off the tower okay don't get
me wrong like my Cortana I like her
concept but I think she didn't tweet yes
she's - she's all provide with raid gear
and what's your current trials gear like
that's a problem people we went into
that last week but at the end of the day
power has to matter and that's the out
of all everything else
I'm loving this Yvonne there's
everything I'm loving what they doing
but I noticed they've been skirting and
not talking about that and I'm I have to
tweet I'm have to take my man you know
CJ I mean CG Barry I have to hit him up
just like Oh what was D I just want to
know what's the rationale behind light
level not mattering what what who made
that decision you know I just want to
know the thought process help me
understand I mean it's like well if they
wanted to try and get the casual people
into the game more so they have more
options to get up to that high level but
when you do that you take away from the
reason to do that hard difficulty looks
like if your light level stops at 300
and the raid gets you to 350 20 and then
the prestige gets you to 330 I mean
maybe the numbers need to be more maybe
it's 300 for the start maybe the raids
350 and the you know prestige is 400 so
those numbers and they can calculate to
where that stuff means something yeah I
don't want to be able to do public
events and be the same as someone who
does a raid and I got the 335 first
before I did this
yeah Republicans getting me dishonest is
the raid is wrong would you say attic
everyone got to 335 that way yeah and
the saddest part attic is when you we
started the raid layer and you like hey
jump in and I'm like no I'm not I'm not
whatever 325 literally fit they don't
matter you like it does not matter
it's no way I was 303 yeah literally
bounces we jumped in I'm 303
nothing's killing us like you know okay
I was like 310 or something like yeah
maybe 310 I was at that point I
literally wasn't even max-level to base
destiny and I have no issues I don't
think I died one time into the very end
of the whole race hey Dad that to me is
an issue this is the hardest content
yeah I was like that's one thing I mean
I mean preach anybody like that it's
like there's a reason some of the
hardest things in something like World
of Warcraft or you have a progression
paced game already don't take away value
of your endgame progression when that's
what people want I mean how many memes
are out there about in-game oh it's like
and it's the John Travolta thing where
he's like looking around it's like in
game in game and it's like and then you
have the in game whatever whatever you
do have for an in game not matter for
light level for progression for
difficulty for I mean all of those
things then ya know I'm and then no
absolutely so I don't like the idea of
you know the monsters being you know
they're always thirty thirty one were
level 32 that was always kind of
frustrating I mean make it something we
can progress to but make it to where you
know every drop counts so if you do the
raid and you start doing like okay we
did the first part of the raid we
couldn't go I get through the second
buddy to get one piece I'm a little
higher next we go get the first one
we'll get something else then we can
progress more I was a stubborn I was
like I'm doing it all this week people
didn't beat some raids for months late
they're afraid of making things I mean
they have horses and they're done in a
day like that stuff should take you know
you should be working that stuff on like
a couple days like maybe if you get
progression you might get up to 320 out
of 350 but that's as much as you can get
this week you can't be at the last boss
down next week you might get enough and
then you might have the damage like or
some crazy group pulls it I mean make
that your in make that stuff harder like
nothing to do that difficulty is gonna
get up there you know great thing you
guys doing here I gave my two cents I'm
about to eat I just got home from work
of awesome talking to you guys and I'll
come back to destiny I've no issue if
anything they're doing you know I see a
step in the right direction
leave an axe Cognito it's always about
the race with me if they if I don't
you know it I will try you know the
second raid we'll see how that goes but
at the end of the day I even tell
Cognito there's nothing wrong with the
rate that they have now the new rate
it's just it's I thought it was a little
too short it had made no sense to the
main storyline and I feel like you know
I feel like that should be one of the
priorities no I agree man and like I
said that's always why we do a
flashpoint well have a hard core kind of
a deep dive but at the same time letting
each part of the community know when
it's safe to come back if for right now
not just yet for you trust me I would
that update come and they start breaking
down I'm gonna start playing it when
they do the high score things again
because I did like that oh yeah that's
come talk to you later I tested it
before I first came in and it sounded
fine but I guess as my phone service you
know people sending you messages on
Facebook and stuff it kept getting worse
and worse
oh good bro I'll talk with you alright
say please do you lordy buy this wrap
this thing up I know we've been going
looked at the time cuz I know you're
using my screens I don't even know what
we're at at this I mean overall yeah
it's definitely been a minute mm-hmm
like a lot of this stuff we're seeing is
good they're working on systems they're
working on quality of life they're
working on the feel of the game and some
of the things that we're talking about
for power mattering and things like that
stuff we'll probably gonna have to wait
for destiny to 2.0 whatever you know
your $40 purchases whatever you're
taking king thingg is gonna be it's
probably a time that they could consider
that things because they can't rebuild
destiny to right now it's that's not
that's not their priority they want to
make a game that at least is out there
working mm-hmm no I agree and and it
just comes down to being practical and
realistic with development schedules you
know and I'm not like I'm not a coder
I know what I want but at the same time
we do have to understand that these
things take time
and you know I know listen long as
they're listening and and as long as
we're getting this transparency that I'm
seeing now these last two updates has
probably been the most transparent about
bugs and thought process and why that's
the main thing community wants to know
why
hasn't this happened yet what what's
going on here what's the holdup you know
and then they're telling us okay this is
why this is what we experienced the
snipers are doing this shaders are doing
that you know yeah yeah yeah all I need
from my wife about this is why power
why is power not matter I've gotta get
little way apparently here didn't even
notice this as wills to be providing
details on the crimson days update going
live on the 13th so apparently crimson
days is gone before that patch so
glanced over just because I hadn't gone
past the videos of the week so is gonna
come without the nightfall scoring kind
of different as they time so yeah
interesting more details on that one
probably next week wouldn't yes yep so
no I'm with you it's like all these
things seem to be good the transparency
is amazing the discussions are good like
I love seeing their thought process and
as I said I'd love to be a fly on a wall
in the whole development process for
anything just for the sniper bug it's
like okay it goes to this guy he's
talking about this one okay this seems
really weird broken right now can you
check this it's like just the whole
process of passing that bug around all
the room and systems like maybe I'd be
an awesome thing to see for a breakdown
and not a lot of people who care about
that but me being stupid nerdy of course
I would no doubt but ya know I mean it's
like hopefully you guys enjoyed this the
week's discussion a lot a lot planned
hopefully they can hit most of those
marks especially those asterisks those
are big ones if they get pushed a little
bit but they're closed maybe those are
like a hotfix later on but they're
closed so if they get an idea then we'll
see but yeah and that pretty much wraps
it up in February already which is kinda
crazy but absolutely we're in February
the ball is rolling and they day like I
said a neighbor named this episode they
do hope they give it at they try to give
us a home and that's all you we're gonna
keep deep diving and doing this thing
man and hoping it gets back to that game
that we love and we still love so much
so hopefully at one of these weeks it
won't be getting longer it will get
shorter it's gotta get shorter because I
mean well first we had a huge update to
go over and then we have a map that's
like months long so after those two big
things drop this will likely get a
little shorter it will ease
to digest but yeah I probably might put
this in the beginning of mine this is
more like a talking head you can
minimize the window just listen to this
video and whatever is gonna be on screen
is nothing important it wasn't in mine
so no doubt alright well let them know
where you're at and we'll can wrap this
thing up yeah lord Cognito here on
twitter so at lord kognito on twitter
also on facebook there's only a facebook
group the destiny tower please join like
driving destiny community there and of
course iron Lords podcast every Sunday
is the Lord's Day 1 p.m. Eastern on the
inner circle Network come check us out
we try to sneak in some destiny there
but we also talk all in multi-platform
gaming latest news and all that good
stuff so come check us out
hey Boches is a regular at the
roundtable you guys definitely keep me
around so that's for me I'm about to see
everywhere twitter twitch youtube you
guys know where to find me
I have been playing more Monster Hunter
so I'll be putting out guides and things
like that it honestly seems like
something that kind of fits in my
wheelhouse of hey here's a guy does and
especially for those solo players just
like I am for guides for monsters and so
many weapons types it's it's a ton of
fun so I'm gonna be having some fun with
that as well as my standard destiny
stuff so more to cover and just kind of
nice to have a little variety for
changes we wait for these things to come
into play and get closer and closer to
the game that we want so absolutely
that's about guys but if you want to do
your sign-off and then I've always got
mine as well get this thing out of here
man and Joe gonna enjoy your day have a
good one and the next flash point will
be coming up catch you later
alright guys and everybody out there
good afternoon good morning Rudy good
evening where have you guys are at
around the world we'll see you soon